we're asked to determine whether each
expression is equivalent to the seventh
root of v to the third power and like
always pause the video and see if you
can figure out which of these are
equivalent to the seventh root of v to
the third power
well a good way to figure out things are
equivalent is to just try to get them
all in the same form so
the seventh root of v to the third power
v to the third power the seventh root of
something is the same thing as raising
it to the one seventh power so this is
equivalent to v to the third power
raised to the one
seventh power and if i raise something
to an exponent and then raise that to an
exponent well then that's the same thing
as raising it to the product of these
two exponents so this is going to be the
same thing as v to the 3
times 1 7 power which of course is 3 7
7. so we've written it in multiple forms
now let's see which of these match so v
to the third to the one seventh power
well that was the form that we have
right over here so that is
equivalent
v to the three sevenths that's what we
have right over here so that one is
definitely equivalent
now let's think about this one this is
the cube root of v to the seventh are is
this going to be equivalent
well
one way to think about it this is going
to be the same thing as
v to the one third power
actually no this wasn't the cube root of
v to the seven this was the cube root of
v and that to the seventh power so
that's the same thing as v to the one
third power and then that to the seventh
power
so that is the same thing as v to the
seven thirds power which is clearly
different than two v to the
three-sevenths power
so this this is not going to be
equivalent for
all v's
all v's for which this expression is
defined let's do a few more of these or
similar types of problems dealing with
with with roots and and fractional
exponents the following equation is true
for g greater than or equal to zero and
d is a constant what is the value of d
well if i'm taking the sixth root of
something that's the same thing as
raising it to the one sixth power
so the
sixth root
sixth root of g to the fifth is the same
thing as g to the fifth
raised to the 1 6 power
and just like we just saw in the last
example that's the same thing as g to
the 5 times 1 6 power this is just our
exponent properties i raise something to
an exponent and then raise that whole
thing to another exponent i can just
multiply the exponents so that's the
same thing as g to the
5 6
power
and so d
is 5 6
5 over 6. the sixth root of g to the
fifth is the same thing as g to the five
sixth power
let's do one more of these
the following equation is true for x
greater than zero and d is a constant
what is the value of d all right this is
interesting and i forgot to tell you in
the last one but but pause this video as
well and see if you can work it out on
or pause for this question as well and
see if you can work it out
well here well let's let's just start
rewriting the root as an exponent so let
me i can rewrite the whole thing this is
the same thing as 1 over instead of
writing the 7th root of x i'll write x
to the 1 7th power
is equal to x to the d
and if i have 1 over something to a
power that's the same thing as that
something raised to the negative of that
power so that is the same thing as x to
the negative
7 power and so that is going to be equal
to x to the d and so d must be equal to
d must be equal to
negative 1 7. so the key here is when
you're taking the reciprocal of
something that's the same thing as
raising it to the negative of that
exponent another way of thinking about
it is
you could view
you could view this as
you could view it as
x
to the one seventh
to the negative one power and then if
you multiply these exponents you get
what we have right over there but either
way d is equal to negative
1 7.